うーわー
ああああああ
はい
はぁ
は
[音楽]
外れちゃうんじゃ16で最後ロスオーダー
大変お待たせしましたあの twitter で個数したらめちゃくちゃ多かった思っ
てくださった皆様本当にありがとうございます
何なんですからツイッターの気楽に書けるのかな youtube のコメントになん
かすごい多かった気がしましたそして今の動画が僕のことで最後の動画になりますもう
2016年最後の質問コーナーなっちゃうでスピードもう古いの間しかないからねもう
ストップでみんな
bouvet てくださー
初コメですキャップんどん兵衛やってください
キャップのは56分あああっっっ
ch
絶対でミョウガだから来ます
今あぁ側のパーはい
denpa
おじいちゃんになってもゆ中盤やるのいつ辞めると考えてるのは俺なんですけど僕は
面白くなくなったら止めますすぐにあっちゃう
結局サンシャインだよし
花希ちゃんかよ羽で迷ったんですけども多分ヨハネです
だで質問おつかれさまでいますたまには息抜きをしてくださいね
ヒカキンさん先週の週末はじめ冊は普通車と撮影しましたね
私も参加しましたあなたに初めに生で見て歯たらすごく綺麗だなと思いましたよ質問
はじめ市場は普段どんなスキンケアを使ってますかぜひ教えてください高校生くらい
からめちゃくちゃ関数の形でフードが何もしなかったもう皮がぼろぼろ剥けてくるん
ですよ
出し方つぐらいからになってからずっと化粧水と乳液ドンキで売ってた化粧せ
とニューイとずっと使ってますし本当とこのかも絶対行ったほうがいいですあ等はお
菓子食べないことかな
以前の親友に恋してますここまで仲がいいからこそ気持ちを伝えることができません
二人で遊びに行ったりもしますもしフラれたら今後遊びに行けなくなるんじゃない
かって思ってしまいますそんなになるなら今の関係でいた方がいいですよね
うわぁ難しする
僕が個人的にその dj のとも立つとにいる友達がいないので女の本音親友がい
るって感覚が僕もわかんないです親友に好意してるっていう時点でも親友じゃない気も
しちゃいますね恋しちゃった時点でも友達にはなれないと僕はございます好きなら好き
でしょ twitter 用や大爆笑してください
明菜に水戸市ば大胆に目は何ですか後肇社長がお勧めしたように目はありますか
ちょっと今年のアニメで言ったら響きユーフォニアムの人気がすごい抜けました
こっそり見てました水槽とか何目なんですけども部活一生懸命頑張ったことある人たち
が見ると多分すっげー感動すると思いますぜひ見てみてくださいヒラリークリントン
抱いてくださいなニュートンが2部屋食べます食べません私には妹がいます
妹はとても頑張り
ですですが体育の授業でどうしてもできない技がありますかしょんぼりしています肇
社長
どうかどうかを誘い基に電気を分けてあげてくださいというわけでこの技やって
ください前方創立回転飛び
いいでしょ
やべ俺がし2も募集する動画て半分冗談で
原人さんも駄目って彫って潰れたらめちゃくちゃ大勢の人か
ng サンゴを食べてえって書いてしまったこれはどうしよう
もう食べるしかないだろん
エンジン3本
食べません最近担任の高橋先生が結婚しました
私たちのことをすごく考えて大変だった時支えてくれてすっごい感謝しています2は
先生が教育実習の時初めて会って今私も他人の先生ですサブライト出店たいので先生に
何かメッセージ下さいお願いしますたハン先生ご結婚おめでとうございます
誰ですか事実をこの後動画にゴミを隠したいって言っていましたので作りました
初めて他のユーチューバーの動画に出ると何か変わるよねなんで人見知りってそういう
もんやでメガなグラーズと性交渉してくださいニットね僕は今高3で進路のことで大学
に行くべきか悩んでいます僕なりにやりたいことがあるのですが親からは大学でき
なさいとなかなか移転がありませんこのまま親の言いなりで大学行ってもなぁと思って
いるんですが始めたつはどう思いますかこれ多分君のやり
たいことに対する熱量によってだと思いますなんとなく行ってみたいなーみたいな感じ
だったら多分大学に行ったほうがいい高校卒業して就職したり専門学校通って言っ
ちゃうと基本的にはもうそんな未知のレイラにもってしまいます凍ったりすることが
できるんですけどなんとなってやりたいなんて思ってるんだったら大学に入って
たくさん時間ができると思うのでその4年間の中で本当
それがやりたいのかどうかっていうことを自分に聞いてみたり他に好きなことができる
かもしれないんで自分がやりたいことに対する熱量次第なんですけども
大学に入って4年間いろんなことを学んで考えるのは軽いかなと思います良い人生を
スキ
もう音速でよ抽出してください武芸ゾーンを振って高さに開けるとなんと勢いと思い
ます
最近 ppap が流行ってますけどはじめ魔王 ppi も好きですか
もちろん大好きですよね大好きですよね
絶対大事ですよねねっ
ね大好きですすぐ将来の弾み雪を太めシャツを
こんな感じで腰振り売り弾としてもう大
[音楽]
君は何を求めているんだねー
見ていいと思うよ一麻
リップクリーム食べてん
[音楽]
これ始めをさせ簡単ですよねこれはちゃったんだねぇ
なんかでしょおいはじめお前何で東京で仕事いくつに室汗見つけてんだよ
遠いとか東京まで行くの大変とかそんなの知らねーんだよでも始めが鋳造かにいる
おかげで静岡の自然豊かなところとか動画でたくさん知ることができてめっちゃ嬉しい
ありがとうのいい奴じゃない会始めちゃう大根で鼻くそほ
ってあーああーー意外と以外ぞ
結構鼻水出るの質問コーナーで初めに一言だけ言いたいことがあります
なんでそんなにカッコいいのでしょうかねあまりにもカッコイイので似顔絵を書いてみ
ましたら嬉しいになっちゃった
社長さん6月あっていうムギちゃん健康に非常によく来蹴り述べて素晴らしいのもの
ですあなたもこちら側に来てください麦じゃうの歯で物にしろ
翼爪うろじゃあベルギーに沿ったんさんにしよう麦茶栄光ライフと
俺って言った艶何
嘘伊那の虎之助を場合は一発矢田一の男たちはジョニーです悲しいですが6の友達は
臭い人ですね暑夏
方法お前がいつしかどれの完全のにしアカウント
dare
親分にタメ口ででましてああまず boss rc
あ
1金を
灰吹元気か入った金庫せもありがとねー
ある人気来年もよろしくた玉
逮捕時はかっ
2いませんでしたーー
大好きだと初めなんかポケモンゴー始まってからすっごいポッポに似てるって言うん
ですけどそんなにてますか
言われてみればいつも応援してます毎日内容の濃い動画ばっかりで笑顔をもらってい
ますこれからも頑張ってください
パプアニューギニアで使い魔はずミスを動画いつも見て元気もらってますありがとう
ございます感謝の気持ちを込めて初めてちょっとトミックを合成してみました
場を持ち始めあっ
回出なかったので画像時しました始めたと聞いてください背負いながら頭やって賞金
カンブリア爆発を呼ばれる生物の9球目てる分覆ったのですかそのカメラでので
サイレンが細く者と呼ばれる穴ばかりすぐカッコ可愛いんです生態系のちょうどに
与するさ c 体の癖フォルモ止まりません出血等の距離は言えばねプロと言われて
しまうのかは陸地とな者厳禁な口も完全に閉じられなかっただけ見ながらも過激になっ
て遊戯わけで近です今までいたからいって言って保存
ちょっとイメージと愛ハーフガードのイメージとのギャップも素晴らしい多田肇社長
ページアナカリス大好きなって下さいお願いしますはいお付けしまでもう少しだから
頑張れよと
頑張れよそこはいったい何台タンスに
たぶんっ
今年の質問コーナーは結構角やタンスに小指をで助けることが多かったらもう何かこれ
もうなんか値切る開かせてしまっている
やべいろいろないとかこれ web つけろと言って狂っ痛いからまぁちょっとぶつけ
てくれ前回と思うほど行ってた雪がアルパ
たけどこれ恋病院とパティとへ
オレはー
俺はもう行きません今年ももうすぐ終わり
和やかに ppp ても聞いて落ち着いて安全に過ごしてください
アイハバカード藍畑小指
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
[拍手]
ああああああああ
[音楽]
andere
goo
バッハ
ああああああああ
来年は何があってもしれません
あのいろいろあったけど楽しい1年でしたぜひ来年も今のときになんとなく暇つぶしに
見えるような動画をポットだしていこうと思いますぜひ来年も真面目冊をよろしくお
願いします
では良いお年よじゃあな